welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to go
back to a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away throughout this video we'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about baby Yoda and the best fan
theories on the cutest character in Star
Wars universe if we're right there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you don't
want to know anything about the future
of the Disney Plus show then I highly
recommend that you turn off now we're
only two episodes into the series so far
but there's a lot of evidence here to
support the things we'll be talking
about and we don't want to ruin the show
for anyone who wants to go in as blind
as possible don't forget to subscribe to
the channel for weekly breakdowns of the
mandalorian as well as a whole host of
other videos and without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of baby Yoda okay so we first
come face-to-face with baby Yoda at the
end of episode one of the mandalorian
the baby has quickly become an entire
mood and has reduced some people online
to tears
I'm not I'm not even kidding the
creature referred to as the asset is a
high-value target that is extremely
sought after by a mysterious Imperial
figure known as the client I'll get into
the reasoning behind this later but it's
highly suggested that the asset is a
very dangerous being that has provided a
wave of death and destruction for all
that I've tried to take it for look at
it it's just so cute anyway the client
seems very blase about whether the
Mandalorian needs to bring it in alive
only stopping to suggest another option
at the insistence of his allied doctor
Pershing upon arriving at the asset the
Mandalorian discovers that several of
the bounty hunters in the area are after
it including IG eleven voiced by Tycho
OTT and later ones that look like they
come from the same species as bosque
though we don't know the identity of the
baby just yet we do know that it is
fifty years into a roughly 900 year life
span and that it comes from the same
species as Yoda now unfortunately we
don't actually know the name of Yoda
species and while several sources list
them is being called Lennox George Lucas
has often refuted this stating that he
wants the race to remain a mystery
when discussing Yoda's origins in an
interview with Moviefone Lucas said
following he's a mystical character he
has no background he comes and he goes
he's the subversive secret mysterious
stranger that enters the film and then
exits at the end it's like poetry they
rhyme Busta Rhymes if he may he may not
have said that aspect this means that we
have no concrete name for them however
there have been a handful that have
popped up in the Star Wars saga mainly a
doll who's similar to Yoda and the baby
are highly force sensitive we know that
these creatures are extremely rare
throughout the entire galaxy and that
they all seemingly have a connection
with the force which is exemplified in
baby Oda who can easily use it even in
its young stages of life on the whole
though they are just referred to as the
quote-unquote Yoda species but who knows
maybe the Mandalorian will clear this up
as we get into it so who is baby Yoda at
the moment online there are a lot of
people asking whoo baby Yoda is with
some people believing that the creature
is literally a younger version of Yoda
however due to the timeline of the show
this is impossible and the events of the
Mandalorian are set five years after The
Return of the Jedi which is the film
that Yoda died in the fact that baby
Yoda is 50 means that it was born
roughly around the same time as Anakin
Skywalker just before the events of the
Phantom Menace and throughout the entire
rise and fall of the Jedi and later the
Empire it was hidden away potentially
due to its abilities so no it's
definitely not Yoda it also exists in a
time where people seem to be unaware
once more of the force Amanda really has
no idea what happened when the creature
was demonstrating its ability to lift
them at all this cements that the Jedi
and Sith have fallen into obscurity and
there's potential and a lot they have
saw how the asset have died when coming
face to face with it because they don't
understand what it can do personally I
believe that mondo only survived because
he showed that he was there to protect
it killing IG 11 and this built the
foundations of the bond that the two now
have but where did it come from well
there have been a lot of theories online
that this baby is the lovechild between
Yoda and yellow and that in the collapse
of the Jedi the latter hid her baby from
the war in order to keep it safe the old
Jedi are not supposed to have
relationships this may have happened
though personally as I'm guessing you
can tell I highly doubt it
one fan theory does suggest that duty
Adil's disappearance in the middle of
the Star Wars prequel trilogy that she
was expelled from the Jedi Order for
bearing a child and with this baby she
set out across the universe to make her
own way we do know that she wasn't
present on the Jedi Council and Revenge
of the Sith and did not perish during
order 66 so it is possible let this
happened though surely Yoda would have
been in trouble too but yeah I guess me
too wasn't around back then anyway if
this did happen then Anakin aka Darth
Vader may have eventually tracked her
down when hunting the Jedi and he could
have killed her as he was unaware of the
child it could have remained hidden like
Luke and Leia and thus made it to the
events of the Mandalorian however there
also exists another pretty big theory
that is currently flowing about online
that says maybe baby Yoda is well just a
baby Yoda and it's in fact a clone of
the character now cloning is a big part
of the Star Wars continuity and even so
far back is 1977's a new hope we had lip
service paid to the Clone Wars which
with the prequels were revealed to
involve stormtroopers that were cloned
on mats from bounty hunter Jango Fett
who could also tie in with mondo in some
way we know on Kamino that this process
could produce direct copies of beings
and even increase or decrease the speed
that they age yet one of the most
interesting things that eagle-eyed
viewers have picked up is that the
enigmatic dr. Pershing who wants baby
Yoda alive more than anyone has a symbol
on his top that is the exact same one
that the Kamino cloners use this
suggests that perhaps his interest in
baby Yoda comes from the fact that he
was involved in the cloning of the
character and this would also explain
why the client knew the rough
whereabouts of where it was I mean who
wouldn't want to clone Yoda and have
their own baby army of Jedi it does make
sense but I am leaning more towards a
theory that baby Yoda is just a victim
of a war-torn galaxy that was sent to
the planet to evade the eyes of the
Empire and that it has remained hidden
there ever since that doesn't mean that
cloning won't come into it though and
personally I do believe that the client
wishes to retrieve it so that he can
mass-produce copies of it this is why
dr. Pershing is involved as he will be
carrying out the procedures that enable
the character to be read
I'm sure Disney will be reproducing it
anyway because of all the toys I mean
who doesn't want a baby Yoda teddy bear
baby Yoda Funko pop baby Yoda socks does
seem that the creature can be cloned
whether it's dead or alive however it
may be easier to clone something living
and this is why dr. Pershing was so
insistent that man no bring baby odor in
unharmed
there's also another theory floating
about online at the moment as well it
says that the baby will actually have
big repercussions for the Star Wars
universe going forward and that there
will be some major tie-ins to the
upcoming movie the rise of Skywalker
you know from trailers and leaked images
that Palpatine aka Darth Sidious will be
returning for the film but many fans
have been curious about how the
character has managed to achieve such a
long lifespan fan theory suggests that
this is partly due to baby Yoda who as
we all know ages very slowly in
comparison to humanoids it is possible
at Palpatine wishes to have baby Oda
brought in for some studying so that he
can see how the creature is able to live
for so long and then he can apply it to
his own life through genetics in order
to make it all the way through the
entire nine movie arc it is an
interesting theory and though we haven't
had any mention of the Mandalorian tying
into Episode nine it's not outside the
realm of possibility we know that the
marble Disney Plus shows will tie in
with the grey MCU so yeah this could
likely happen going forward with baby
Yoda there's just so many things that
can happen when the Mandalorian reaches
the client but one thing that we do know
that won't happen is that he will hand
it over without a fight I mean just look
at that face just just look at it you
can kind of see why makes some people
wanna cry anyway it's clear that they've
both grown an attachment to one another
and it would be awesome to see these two
going around the galaxy together
actually though thinking about it yeah
would it would be pretty funny if he
just handed it over and took the money
and left and it would be the final fu to
Star Wars fans
Kathleen Kennedy's ultimate end game she
is the real Darth Sidious it turns out
overall though I'm massively excited to
see where the show goes and I guess we
will find out what is really going on
when mando returns to the client for
episode 3 obviously I'd love to your
thoughts on baby Yoda and if you agree
with any of the theories or if you have
your
even better one if you're from the
future or have the foresight of a fully
trained Jedi Knight then drop the truth
about the character in the comments
section below and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
youtube series which breaks down every
episode of the Mandalorian so far we
cover all the Easter eggs things you
missed and give our theories going
forward so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me in
twitter at definition white tea or head
over to my discord server which should
be linked in the description below we
drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else
then that's the best place to be it's
free to join and we have an awesome
community so hopefully I see you over
there very soon we're also giving away a
free copy of the marble phase 3 part 2
box set on blu-ray which contains Black
Panther infinity war and Game Captain
Marvel and more and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning it's
like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on baby odor in the comments
section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of December and the set will be shipped
out from then to ever get surprised it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to Definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you